die neuen raumanzüge die die nasa jetzt
vorgestellt hat sind echte allround
talente mit ihnen können die astronauten
astronauten bei der nächsten
mond-mission wohl geschmeidig über die
oberfläche laufen anstatt so zu hüpfen
wie ein hase wie damals noch die apollo
generation der orangefarbene sogenannte
orion crew survivals zug soll auf dem
weg in richtung mond getragen werden und
würde das überleben der kuh für ganze
sechs tage sicher selbst wenn der druck
innerhalb des raumschiffes plötzlich und
unerwartet sind fix und foxi hier gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen einer der
beiden neu konstruierten raumanzüge der
nasa heißt exploration extra wie tequila
mobility juni ticks und ist weiß rot und
blau und er macht künftigen astronauten
astronauten das leben wohl sehr viel
einfacher denn im vergleich zum apollo
modell beschert er deutlich mehr
bewegungsfreiheit und ist zudem passend
für männer und frauen eine echte
premiere denn das hatte sich in der
vergangenheit ja als kompliziert
herausgestellt zur erinnerung erst im
märz diesen jahres 2009 10 musste die
nasa den ersten geplanten
weltraumeinsatz der nur von frauen
durchgeführt werden sollte absagen
inzwischen hat er ja stattgefunden aber
der grund damals nicht genügend passende
raumanzüge doch damit ist jetzt schluss
denn die neuen raumanzüge in
einheitsgröße lassen sich ohne probleme
an die jeweilige astronauten bzw an den
jeweiligen astronauten anpassen doch
nicht nur das die nasa ingenieuren
kristin davis zeigt bei der präsentation
wie sie sich in dem anzug drücken kann
und gegenstände vom mond aufheben kann
ohne dabei das gleichgewicht zu
verlieren eine extrem wichtige sache für
die erkundung des mondes dazu kristin
davis die mobilität ist sehr wichtig für
unsere arbeit wenn man einen stein
aufheben möchte wenn man ein
wissenschaftliches instrument einsetzen
möchte dann braucht man diese oberkörper
beweglichkeit auch die arme über den
kopf zu heben scheint keine probleme zu
bereiten und noch eine entscheidende
sache ermöglicht dieser neu entwickelte
raumanzug dazu jim brittens teil der
chef der nasa wenn wir uns an die apollo
generation erinnern erinnern wir uns
daran wie neil armstrong und buzz augen
wie h
über die mondoberfläche gehüpft sind
jetzt wird es uns möglich sein über die
mondoberfläche zu laufen das ist ganz
anders als bei den früheren anziehen
er betonte noch einmal dass die nasa die
landung auf dem mond quasi nur als ein
zwischenziel sieht letztendlich lautet
das ziel wir wollen zum mars und um zum
mars zu gelangen müssen wir den mond als
testgelände nutzen doch das modell
expiration extra wie cola mobility juni
tags new beschert nicht nur mehr
bewegungsfreiheit hinzu kommen zwei
weitere technische neuigkeiten zum einen
schützt der anzug die astronautin den
astronauten von extremtemperaturen
umgebungstemperaturen von minus 157 grad
bis hin zu plus 121 grad soll durch den
modularen aufbau des anzuges für die
menschen in ihm auszuhalten sein dazu
nasa ingenieuren amy ross wenn wir auf
den mars fliegen dann brauchen wir eine
neue isolierung denn dort gibt es eine
atmosphäre die zweite technische
neuerung führt dazu dass das system zur
absorption von kohlendioxid besser
funktioniert das gas entsteht ja bei der
atmung der astronautinnen astronauten
und konnte von den bisherigen
raumanzügen nur bis zu einem bestimmten
sättigungsgrad aufgenommen werden
das neue modell ex eu aber ist in der
lage das gas nach außen ins all
abzugeben neben diesen neu entwickelten
raumanzug wurde der öffentlichkeit eine
weitere entwicklung präsentiert der
orangefarbene all inclusive landshut
gedacht ist dieser für die reise zum
mond die ja für das jahr 2024 geplant
ist erstmals seit 1972 sollen dann
wieder menschen auf den mond seien auf
dem weg dorthin könnten die astronauten
astronauten den orangefarbenen anzug in
der raumfähre tragen im worst case
beispielsweise wenn ein metroid die
außenwand des raumschiffes beschädigt
oder gar durch trinkt könnte der euren
crew survive es tut das überleben der
crew sichern und zwar bis zu sechs tage
lang denn in einem notfall kann der
anzug die astronautin astronauten
stabilisieren beispielsweise wenn es zu
einem plötzlichen unerwarteten
druckabfall kommt es scheint doch
langsam konkret mit der landung auf dem
mond 2024 zu werden fünf fakten über die
erste mondlandung anklicken anschauen
und us comics tv abonnieren kostet ja
nix
bis dann bleibt dran und hier
draufklicken